une menace de plus la menace de trop
pour avoir berger qui a rendu public sur
Twitter une lettre manuscrite et anonyme
reçu dernièrement il est si petit son
rejetons il ne pourra pas s'enfuir feu
batte de baseball barre de fer tout est
bon pour vous éradiquer
à quant à elle portait plainte après
avoir reçu des menaces antisémites du
même auteur selon elle que la chef de
file les députés Renaissance face à la
crise le président reprend les manettes
et impose ses priorités à Elisabeth
borne d'abord tendre la main au syndicat
et à Laurent Berger pour parler
usure professionnelle pénibilité mais
aussi revoir les 64 ans demande le chef
de la CFDT je suis né à 27 mais à 27
octobre cette fois-ci en 68 forcément
très exposé à la télé et souvent dans la
rue en ce moment ma couleur ou celle de
mon syndicat c'est le orange je serai
l'invité des 4 V je suis je suis je suis
à
le patron de la CFDT oui c'est ça
comment il s'appelle Laurent
Berger il faut un bouger du gouvernement
très fort sur la question des retraites
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils disent
les 64 ans ne s'appliqueront pas et on
rediscute des retraites et du travail
l'exécutif souhaite avancer sur la
question du travail ou encore de l'école
la première ministre se donne trois
semaines pour consulter et mettre au
point une nouvelle méthode elle promet
déjà de ne plus recourir à l'article
49-3 hors texte budgétaire la
constitution de toute façon ne le permet
qu'une fois par session parlementaire
mais encore faut-il que les bonnes
intentions soient suivies des faits
un piquet de grève devant l'un des
monuments les plus visités de France
le Louvre fermé aujourd'hui des
centaines de touristes prillés de faire
demi-tour c'est fermé aujourd'hui c'est
pas le bon moment pour venir en France
on est venu manif
ester pour
la publique et on est contre la réforme
contre la réforme
la France en colère
[Applaudissements]
il n'a pas lu La Tribune qu'il a signé
et son vœu Squeezie le vidéaste le plus
suivi de France regrette de faire partie
des 150 créateurs de contenu à s'opposer
dans le JDD au projet de loi sur
l'encadrement des influenceurs il n'est
pas seul nozman aussi ne cautionne plus
ce texte qui demande au députés de ne
pas casser leur modèle à cause d'une
minorité d'influenceurs malhonnête si
certains n'ont pas lu La Tribune
d'autres présents dans la liste
affirment même ne jamais l'avoir signé
parmi eux Gotaga Henry Tran ou encore
Cyprien les chéris je vais vous dire la
vérité parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
j'ai vu qu'il y avait dit ouais Thierry
na les influenceurs mais si vous savez
comme je m'en carre le cul mais vous
savez même pas comment c'est à dire
vraiment je m'en tape mais d'une force
mais vraiment voilà donc sachez-le je
voilà je je vais vous dire moi sorti de
vous qui nous regardez tous les soirs et
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
c'est mon c'est mon moteur le paddle et
ma vie je vais vous dire il y a peu de
choses qui m'intéresse
quand on reconnaît cet homme
c'est totalement pardonné
parce que rien que pour ça
[Applaudissements]
ça fait partie du moyen de se faire
pardonner
ce soir le dernier événement de la manif
pour tous
comme quoi la Lune est pas si mauvaise
aujourd'hui que
la musique
j'ai l'honneur de vous annoncer que la
manif pour tous devient ce soir à
l'instant je vous parle le syndicat de
la famille
fausse alerte il y a que le long qui
change je pense que ce qui vous
intéresse c'est plus les caméras que le
combat non mais c'est vrai je pense que
vous y êtes allés pour faire des Tik Tok
c'était une manif contre la réforme des
retraites ça aurait été une manif contre
les trottinettes vous y seriez allé
aussi c'est la même chose
je suis désolé moi je vois des milliers
des millions de manifestants dans toute
la France ils ont des pancartes avec des
messages pas des perches à selfies et au
lieu de vous demander quand est-ce que
vous allez partir à la retraite
demandez-vous quand est-ce que vous
allez commencer un vrai boulot plutôt
c'est ça
au dossier chaud des retraites c'est à
Julie la colère contre les méga bassines
ce week-end non au Méga bassine oui
Oméga retraite il y avait surtout un
code couleur qui a attiré notre
attention
vous avez sur quoi c'est moyen et jaune
c'est vénère des affrontements à Sainte
Soline il ne reste que les traces des
véhicules calcinés d'états de munitions
et des champs ravagés par le passage des
manifestants comme chez cet agriculteur
sa parcelle se trouvait sur le chemin du
cortège
c'est des salles de blé dur qui sont
cassées qui repartiront pas des dégâts
parfois ciblés les activistes ce sont
également attaqués à son système
d'irrigation
vous êtes content qu'il y ait une
fraction du mouvement qui soit plus
radicale mais là on nous entend pas donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
62 couteaux 67 boules de pétanque cet
artifice si Biton bidon d'essence 12
pierres et parpaing 13 h et machette 5
matraques des battes de baseball
également tout ça a été retrouvé sur des
manifestants B donc le bilan 47
gendarmes blessés un manifestant de 30
ans tu l'as dit dans le coma après un
traumatisme crânien trois manifestants
en tout dont une femme de 19 ans et un
autre homme de 27 ans grève en blessé
tout ça pour des bassines d'eau au 2006
on vient se rendre compte que nous notre
défense c'est des cailloux donc ce qu'on
trouve dans le champ et des parapluies
et derrière on fait face à des mecs qui
sont armés jusqu'aux dents et qui sont
il y a quand même des voitures de
gendarmerie qui ont brûlé
ouais la question de l'écologie
violente elle est elle est réelle
puisque la crise écologique elle est
réelle et on a quand même le sentiment
que les gouvernants bien sous-tour
rapport n'agissent pas suffisamment dans
le sens de l'écologie donc on verra
peut-être que dans quelques années on
s'apercevra que les adversaires des
bassines et dans l'ensemble les
militants écolos y compris les militants
violents étaient ceux qui avaient raison
qu'est-ce qu'on a récolté aujourd'hui
alors si on pourrait faire un quiz
potager pour voir si vous connaissez les
légumes mais en gros on a un beau cageot
de belles betteraves
avec ça tu fais la couverture de
betterave magazine clairement